it's my pleasure to present the silver  medal award and alternative filmmaking  to Emily Henrik's so um first I'd like  to thank my mom mom I can't find words  to describe how thankful I am for  everything you do for our family and me  so I love you very much I also want to  thank the rest of my family Andy dad  Evan EJ and Eden I want to thank my  boyfriend Jamie who was walking all over  that screen I also want to thank my  brilliant composer sherry Chung I want  to thank the USC data faculty and staff  for their help and encouragement  especially Mike Patterson and Candice  rec injure for their guidance and help  on this project I want to thank all my  friends for all their support and I also  want to thank the academy it's really  cool to say Oh for honoring me with such  an award it's been a really great couple  of days very inspiring and I feel very  lucky thank you